hello everybody and welcome to the last
section of the bitcoin protocol paper
the conclusion this is not going to be
the end of this series i know a lot of
you guys were like oh man it's the end
nope
don't worry there are a lot of
implications that come out of
this paper and mostly the protocol that
aren't directly
addressed so i do plan to address at
least some of those
with that let's go ahead and tackle this
conclusion
we have proposed a system for electronic
transactions without relying on trust
we started with the usual framework of
coins made from digital signatures which
provide
strong controls of ownership
but is incomplete without a way to
prevent double spending
to solve this we proposed a peer-to-peer
network using proof-of-work
to record a public history of
transactions that quickly becomes
computationally impractical for an
attacker to change if honest nodes
control
a majority of cpu power the network is
robust in its unstructured simplicity
nodes work all at once with little
coordination they don't need to be
identified since messages are not
rooted to any particular place and only
need to be delivered on a best
effort basis nodes can re leave and
rejoin the network at will
accepting the proof of work chain as
proof of what happened
while they were gone they vote with
their cpu power
expressing their acceptance of valid
blocks by working on extending them
and rejecting invalid blocks by refusing
to work on them
any needed rules and incentives can be
enforced with this
consensus mechanism and that ends the
paper
quite possibly the most powerful line is
in this last paragraph
and it's the very last line of any
needed rules and incentives can be
enforced with this consensus mechanism
referring to one cpu one vote this is
really what opens the door
to pretty much anything including
bitcoin's evolution
so changes to the bitcoin protocol can
be made that the bitcoin protocol is
just open source code so someone can
edit that code
and pass it along and so long as the
nodes support it
it will pass most importantly the
combination of
rule changes is what's voted on not you
know it wouldn't necessarily just be one
rule at a time
and you wouldn't you like couldn't
piggyback rules on each other like we do
with laws today
uh if nodes don't support it it simply
won't pass
simple as that one cpu one
vote this also has some implications
because it's not
one person one vote it is cpu power
therefore you could assert that this
voting system favors the wealthy who can
afford
to buy more cpu power my response to
that is that the wealthy who are indeed
supporting the network
with their money
should and should get that extra voting
power and also there could be wealthy
people who choose not to support the
network as much
and wouldn't get that voted voting power
also i think it's important not to get
too tied up here as you're probably
viewing like this idea of a wealthy vote
being
able to overpower middle-class vote in
terms of you know sheer money
and i think you're viewing the world
through the glass
of our world today you're framing it
around our current world
where this very you know income
inequality gap with
you know the richest people holding the
most money in the world
is really the result of corrupt politics
because
politicians are people and people are
easily fallible
and misrepresent the people who voted
them to get into office
and represent them there are multiple
reasons today
why the wealthy have so much of this
aggregated power and wealth today
but quite a bit of it is the direct
result
of greeting corruption within politics
so if you had a clean voting system
where everyone truly does have a say
and laws aren't piggybacked on each
other and we don't have to rely on
someone to do what they said
or be transparent the actual system
the system in it quality and uh
just the whole you know ecosystem of
this structure
will be completely different and it
would be extremely fair
and as far as the wealthy you know
having more of a vote let's say
i think that would be better seen as
people who participate
most in the network get the most out of
it because wealthy people can use their
wealthy
their money to do other things and other
forms of business and stuff so if
they're choosing to do it and work with
the network
then they're really actually
participating more in the network so
they do get more of a vote because
they're a bigger part of the network
but more on the possibility of that in a
future video since i would like to cover
some of the other things that bitcoin
has brought
as a possibility into this world so a
lot of really interesting concepts
mostly based
on the protocol not necessarily money
because
bitcoin as money is really just the
first medium
that is exchanged over the bitcoin
protocol
but you can exchange anything over the
bitcoin protocol
contracts money cars
whatever you can do at businesses
anything
anything can go over this protocol and
this protocol can be used
for any motive transfer and any voting
so anyways congratulations on making it
to the end i hope i've been able to help
those of you who cared to learn more
about bitcoin in the bitcoin protocol
if you have any questions or comments
leave them below as usual
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support in the subscriptions and until
next time